[Applause]
they're raising cost and selling data
cuz Disney fans said see you later yeah
their desperate attempt to recover from
failing attendance Disney's raised theme
park ticket prices by as much as 21%
they also signed a deal with Tik Tok
where the Chinese owned app will provide
Disney with content promotion and fan
engagement as you know Tik Tok is owned
by China responsible for other great
Imports like Co child slaves and kungpow
chicken so has Disney really lost touch
with reality maybe judging by their
latest
[Music]
cartoon all right listen up I've been
doing a lot of soul searching in prison
and I've got something to say I think
the Chinese government are the good guys
finally we hate America just like you
yep we should destroy those capitalist
pigs child labor means cheaper products
you're right Goofy and with all the
savings that means more money for drugs
and hookers awesome oh boy let's go do
Coke and have an orgy in the Epcot
[Music]
Center Tyrus uh you got a you got a
sizable family how would you change
Disney like it seems like they've just
abandoned their core mission statement
how would I change Disney uh how many
bulldozers do I
get I don't go even before Disney went
woke uh I was never a big Disney fan
because I don't like adults with Mouse
hats and you got my we don't play the
Disney adults it's for children let it
go it's over you can't get it back with
all the stuff that's going on my family
had planned a a trip to France and
they're going to the lou and the Versa
and French Disney to which I said stupid
idea but they say what do you know like
I'm paying for it but I'm not going
that's how I get out of it and with all
the stuff that's going on right now the
Versailles the Lou all these places that
they were going to stay every one of
them said if you choose given the
certainty of what's going on we're happy
to give you a refund or reschedule hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else